et il est évident que lorsque vous
comparez les scores pisa lorsque vous
êtes fait ce type d' analyse nous savons
que là ce qui a joué parfois en
aggravant la situation du milieu social
ça pouvait être le fait que vous êtes
enfants issus de l'immigration d'une
immigration récente et que des leurres
vos parents n'avaient pas le capital
scolaire
et c'est bien connu qui vous permet dès
la maternelle
de plus rapidement d'abord les
apprentissages fondamentaux
concrètement votre mère vous lit une
histoire une fois ou deux fois par
semaine et vous lis des livres etc
c'est il faut quand même le rappeler
parce que c'est connu quand on fait des
comparaisons des performances des
systèmes éducatifs et c'est un élément
oui mais c'est compliqué sont de moins
en moins nombreux à avoir des résultats
oui mais parce que effectivement c'est
une des variables par exemple on sait
très bien c'est est décrit dans un livre
d'hugues lagrange sait très bien que la
taille des fratries variable selon les
selon les flux migratoires elle a des
effets importants sur la performance des
enfants c'est pour ça que tout ce qui
pouvait ça fait depuis des années que
les spécialistes de l'éducation savent
que pour améliorer éviter la
reproduction sociale et introduire
d'égalité dans ce système outre les
aspects de cartes que vous évoquez
l'autre point important c'est un la
taille des classes et de saab est le don
quelle est la question des fratries
c'est surtout l'accent qui doit être mis
sur le cp
là la maternelle la grande section c'est
à dire le sait ce que l'on fait bien sûr
mais ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
demandez-vous depuis combien de temps
nous nous faisons depuis combien de
temps il a été décidé de mettre en
oeuvre
là où ça doit être fait c'est à dire le
plus tôt possible en maternelle une
politique qui permet cette égalité des
chances dès le plus jeune âge parce que
moi j'ai connu ça il ya plusieurs années
j'ai monté avec l'éducation nationale un
grand réseau de 80 grandes entreprises
françaises soutenues par l'éducation
nationale qui est un réel avec une
charte on a fait ça soude gilles de
robien
c'est le réseau des entreprises un
service de l'égalité des chances très
bien oui non mais c'est très bien mais
moi je me souviens très bien quand j'ai
expliqué aux gens du monde de
l'entreprise aux uns et aux autres je
vous parle de ça il ya quinze ou vingt
ans qu'on leur disait mais quand même il
faudrait pas simplement on s'intéressé
aux jeunes qui veulent rentrer à science
aux accès aux grandes écoles
peut-être qu'on pourrait s'intéresser à
la maternelle jambes regarder les hurons
c'est pas le sujet et de plus et c'est
en effet depuis jean michel blanc car
hélas qu'on a mis en oeuvre cette idée
contre qui est une évidence scientifique
mais bien connu qui est que la taille
des classes avaient un effet